de vuelta del trabajo ewan da clases en
un centro de formación continua en un
suburbio de Bristol un incidente en una
de las aulas Que obviamente no tiene
suficiente personal los estudiantes
empezaron a dar patadas muchos de esos
alumnos tienen autismo dislexia fueron
necesarios varios miembros del personal
para calmar a los alumnos y devolverlos
a la clase
este asistente de profesora acaba de
encontrar una habitación en un
apartamento compartido pero el alquiler
en Bristol es caro el aumento del coste
de vida y la subida de las facturas de
energía hacen que sea difícil llegar a
fin de mes
mi sueldo mensual es de algo más de 1000
libras antes mi alquiler era de 500
libras con las facturas llegaba a 700 u
800 libras Así que te quedan unas 200
libras para comida médicos y cosas así
todos estamos escribiendo nuestro
currículum en este momento nos quedamos
por los estudiantes no quiero abandonar
a mis alumnos son niños que no han hecho
nada malo
dificultades de aprendizaje y proceden
de determinados entornos
[Música]
tiene un máster en literatura inglesa y
trabaja a tiempo completo en la
universidad aún así A veces se ve
obligado acudir a los bancos de
alimentos
esta sería mi comida de esta noche
muchos profesores tienen varios trabajos
como la novia de Iván que hace de
canguro después de clase cree que el
gobierno debería valorar más a los
trabajadores del sector público los que
están en primera línea
esas personas que dedican su vida
laboral diaria a cuidar de los demás
especialmente de las personas
vulnerables que no se ocupen de ellos no
solo te desilusionas sino que hace que
muchos de nosotros queramos mudarnos no
solo de casa sino al extranjero Así que
la mayoría de mi familia quiere irse a
Australia a Nueva Zelanda a Estados
Unidos porque son solo mejores salarios
casi un tercio de los profesores
renuncian tras menos de cinco años en el
puesto el sector privado suele ser más
atractivo y las escuelas se esfuerzan
por cubrir las vacantes los sindicatos
hablan de una situación desesperada con
los niveles educativos en peligro